welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy the ladies
call
grand admiral prawn and this video are
breaking down
everything you need to know about the
big star wars villain over the years
as the canon of the franchise changed so
did certain things about the character
but throughout this video we're going to
be bringing you the most important
points about him
and our theories for where things could
be going in the future
now thrawn was actually born under the
name kivu raw nuru
which if you mate with him he'll let you
shorten to vuron
he's also gone under the name mithra
nuru odo
but obviously no one has any fun saying
that especially me as i had to re-record
the video seven times to get that right
so for this we're just gonna be
referring to him as thrawn
now thrawn has a very memorable
appearance and the character stands out
for a number of reasons he's pretty much
always seen in a striking white uniform
and this makes him leap out amongst all
the imperial forces
who tend to wear black and dark colours
when they're at work
on the days off though they can be seen
during a hawaiian [ __ ]
and partying like it's their last day on
core ascent
which spoiler alert it probably is now
thrawn also has blue skin and red eyes
as well as cheekbones that would make
janet jackson jealous
and dark blue hair this has changed over
the years and depending on what you read
or watch it can
be gray black or a number of colors but
for me
i imagine it is being navy-ish just
because of the stuff that i've been
brought up upon
like i said the continuity has changed
several times as well
but i'll be sticking to the most
up-to-date one as that's probably what's
going to be brought across to the
properties
going forward for the future now very
little is known about thrawn's childhood
but we do know that he was born on
rental and that he became an officer of
the chiss ascendency
due to his ruthless and strategic mind
thrawn quickly rose through the ranks
and he was integral to the defense fleet
of the chess
rental is actually part of the unknown
regions of the galaxy
and taron decided to part from his home
in order to explore other parts of space
upon doing this the character actually
came across anakin skywalker
and made an unlikely ally out of him
thrawn actually held anakin to find
padme
and thus the jedi ended up owing a lot
to the character
thrawn wanted to learn all that he could
about the clone wars
and actually got to see a large chunk of
them first hand
thrawn fought alongside anakin at one
point against a large amount of droids
and anakin was extremely impressed by
his combat prowess
now throne shared a mutual respect for
him as well and the two did eventually
become
heavily linked to the empire this is
mainly because when skywalker returned
to core ascent
he told palpatine about thrawn and
palpates told him
the story of darth plagueis the wise
which reminds me did i
did i ever tell you about about the
story of darth plagueis the wise
no never mind now palpatine naturally
took an interest to the character but
much to everyone's surprise thrawn was
really unimpressed with the way that
things were running in the republic
he didn't actually think it was fit to
join with the chiss and thought that
democracy was a stupid style of
governing as it led to everyone getting
to put their point across
which meant nothing ever really got done
clearly palpatine thought this too
and we all know how things changed after
order 66 helped to make the galaxy great
again
this reorganizing of the planets under
one rule of imperial force
was more in line with the vision that
thrawn had for the galaxy
and thus he ended up joining the
galactic empire this allegiance would be
highly beneficial to the chiss
and he integrated with galactic society
very quickly
thrawn went to the royal imperial
academy on coruscent
and gained numerous promotions before
the emperor bestowed on him the rank of
grand admiral
this was extremely rare and he's pretty
much one of the only aliens in the
entire organization
typically imperial officers tend to just
be white dudes
and being from another species is often
frowned upon
thus we know that in order to be
accepted into it
thrawn must have been something special
and it's clear that his skill and
tactical mind helped him to bypass
several of the prejudices that existed
within the empire
now because of this thrawn commanded a
massive amount of soldiers throughout
the galaxy
and these were known as the seventh
fleet his i-class star destroyer was
called the chimera
and that was deployed to the lothal
sector before the rise of the rebellion
he actually features quite heavily in
the animated series rebels
and during his time he worked alongside
darth vader
and is arguably one of the most
intimidating figures in the imperial
lineup
now what makes thrawn stand out from his
imperial colleagues
is his willingness to try and understand
his enemy
whereas most of the empire are happy
stamping out all that trying to pose
them
thrawn actually sees his enemies as an
opportunity to learn
because of this he studied the jedi
mandalorians and rebellion
trying to learn all the ins and outs of
their operations so that he can exploit
their weaknesses
and the character did come face to face
with ezra bridger
star of rebels and after the pair were
pulled into hyperspace
he disappeared for a long time during
this the battle of endor happened
and as we know the empire fell and there
was apparently peace amongst the galaxy
once more
however in the unknown regions thrawn
once more plotted away
and in the uncharted areas he was able
to gather his forces again
and he actually went on to form the
first order now we know
very little about what has happened with
the character since then
but due to the latest episode of the
mandalorian it does seem like he's going
to be playing a big part going forward
at the end of season 2 episode 5 it's
revealed that ahsoka is actually hunting
him
and trying to track down his location
which going by the timeline
puts him in the unknown regions
alongside ezra
now why this is important is because at
the end of rebels
ahsoka actually teamed up with sabine in
order to try and track him down
ezra had obviously disappeared and that
she was attempting to get to the bottom
of where he was
alongside ren however what's interesting
about the latest episode
is that ren isn't brought up at all now
what could be going on here is that
thrawn has actually managed
to capture ren and this is why asuka
wants to find him
either that or she knows ezra is
withdrawn and for some reason or other
ren is off doing her own thing now there
are several possibilities
and we won't know for definite until
things come to the forefront
but hey this is a heavy spoilers video
so you know we like to theorize and
speculate
now i think ren could indeed be off by
herself looking for clues
and perhaps the pair split up in order
to cover more ground
so that they could find the location of
thrawn quicker
or they already found ezra and he and
ren went off together
or or or like i said
thrawn has him and ahsoka is simply
trying to get him to kill two birds with
one stone
i don't know now we do have it confirmed
from giancarlo esposito that moff gideon
will continue to be the big bad going
into season three
i was kind of thinking that perhaps
thrawn would be teased here
everyone would team up to kill gideon
and then we would get a teaser of thrawn
being aware of what's going on
and that that could set up the character
as the villain for season three
however unless esposito is lying it
doesn't seem like things are going to be
going that way
now there are a lot of rumors that
there's going to be several spin-off
shows in the saga
involving characters like ahsoka sabine
obi-wan and a lot more
potentially ahsoka could be going off
and doing her own thing
in which thrawn will be the villain and
i'd love to see someone like mads
mikkelsen becoming the big bad guy
i know he was in rogue one yeah but
warrick davis has been like 50 different
characters in star wars
just let me dream yeah that that would
be my perfect throne
anyway that's pretty much everything you
need to know and our theories on him
so i hope you enjoyed the video as much
as i enjoyed making it
and my editor hated editing it now
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the character and what you want to
see from him in the future
if you had some fun then please drop a
thumbs up and make sure you check out
our full breakdown of season 2 episode 5
which is going to be linked at the end
we've also done a video detailing
everything you need to know about the
child
so check it out after this don't forget
we're giving away three copies of the
marvel phase two box set
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of november so make sure you
get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat it's on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter
thanks for making it to the end of the
video you've been the best i've been
both i'll see you next time take care
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you